we just finished demonstrating how to
calculate opportunity costs and
determine who has the comparative
advantage in a goods production using
the data provided at an output table or
production possibilities curve in that
video we had a table showing the
potential output of two goods that two
countries could produce with the fixed
amount of inputs
in this video we're going to look at how
to calculate opportunity costs and
determine who has a comparative
advantage to two goods production using
the information from what we call an
input table let's look at this table and
discuss how it differs from the
information provided in the table in the
previous video
notice that in this table we are given
not the number of units of output that
the two countries can produce rather we
are given the number of workers needed
to produce a single unit of output
so the variable in this table is the
number of inputs needed to produce a
thousand watermelons
or a single bicycle with this
information we can calculate the
opportunity costs of watermelons and
bicycles in these two countries and
determine who has the comparative
advantage in the two goods production
let's start with watermelons and country
x
i find it very helpful to tell a story
when calculated opportunity costs using
data from an input table
the four workers needed to produce a
single watermelon could have produced
how many bicycles four workers could
have only produced four twelfths
of a bicycle because you would have
needed three times that many workers in
order to produce a single bicycle that
means that per thousand watermelons this
country is giving up only one third of a
bicycle
now i'm going to go ahead and convert
that once again to a decimal to make it
easier to compare opportunity costs
between the two countries so one-third
of a bicycle
means that the opportunity cost of
watermelons is 0.33 bicycles per
watermelon for bicycles
12 workers are needed the question is
how many watermelons could those 12
workers have produced and the answer to
that is 12 divided by four
because three times as many workers are
needed to produce a single bicycle as
are needed to produce a thousand
watermelons so the opportunity cost of
bicycles in terms of watermelons is what
could have been produced with those
twelve workers
which is three watermelons or in fact
three thousand watermelons say say a
thousand here
three thousand watermelons are given up
for every bicycle produced because the
12 workers needed to produce a bicycle
could have produced 12 over four
watermelons
let's do a similar method to calculate
the opportunity cost of watermelons and
bicycles in country y
the six workers needed to produce 1 000
watermelons how many bicycles could they
have produced
well they would have needed 24 workers
to produce a single bicycle therefore in
country y 6 over 24
bicycles are given up in order to
produce 1 000 watermelons that is 1 4
bicycle per watermelon convert that to a
decimal i get 0.25 bicycles per
watermelon
how about
bicycles what's the opportunity cost of
bicycles how many watermelons could
those 24 workers have produced well only
six workers are needed to produce a
thousand watermelons
so the opportunity cost of each bicycle
is the
4 000 watermelons that could have been
produced
using the 24 workers needed to produce a
single bicycle
we now have our opportunity costs
of bicycles and watermelons in these two
countries the next thing we need to do
is simply determine who has the lower
opportunity cost for watermelons and who
has a lower opportunity cost for
bicycles to determine who should
specialize based on the principle of
comparative advantage
let's start with watermelons we can see
right away that a single watermelon
costs
less of a bicycle
in country y than it does in country x
only one quarter or 0.25
bicycles are given up compared to 0.33
in country x that gives country y a
comparative advantage in watermelon
production
and yes predictably country x therefore
has a comparative advantage in
bicycle production country x gives up
only 3 000 watermelons for every bicycle
it produces whereas countrywide gives up
4 000 watermelons for every bicycle it
produces
based on these calculations we can come
to the following conclusions country x
should specialize in the production of
bicycles
because it has the lower opportunity
cost compared to country y next country
y
should specialize in the production of
watermelons
since it can produce watermelons at a
lower opportunity cost of 0.25 bicycles
per watermelon
compared to country x which must give up
0.33 bicycles per watermelon so how do
the two countries get the goods that
they do not produce domestically they
should trade with one another and
through trade
both countries can enjoy the good that
they are not producing domestically at a
lower opportunity cost than they could
have produced it at domestically to
review the difference between what we
call an input table and what we call an
output table is that the variable given
to us is not the number of units of
output that can be produced rather it is
the number of units of inputs needed to
produce a single unit of output the
input in this table was the number of
workers needed to grow a thousand
watermelons and the number of workers
needed to produce a single bicycle we
can calculate opportunity costs and
determine who has a comparative
advantage in two goods productions from
the data in an input table